Narrator: It's been 10 years
since "Shark Tank"
ignited America's
entrepreneurial spirit,
and we're still blazing a trail
for those who take their fate
into their own hands.
Tonight, Sara Blakely,
the founder of Spanx
and one of the wealthiest
self‐made women in the world,
returns to the Tank.
I see so many similarities
from my journey with you guys.
Both: Thank you.
You've made no money.
That's very depressing.
‐Oh.
I feel like
I'm at a wake.
[ Laughter ]
Both: Oh, no!
It's really starting
to come down!
When you're first starting
a business, make it, sell it.
We sold 20,000 units
in four hours.
‐Wow!
‐Unbelievable.
This is your moment.
Yes or no?
‐We'll make you proud.
‐Aah!
I can't see! I can't see!
I actually think I'm growing
hair on my chest.
♪♪
‐Oh!
‐I'm out.
Pass it on.
Boom.
Kevin.
‐Shazam.
Boom,
and boom.
‐Ladies.
Don't say "ladies."
Say "majority."
♪♪
Narrator:
First into the Tank is a way to
protect a valuable accessory.
♪♪
Hi, I'm Morgan.
And I'm Arley,
and we're seeking $300,000
for 25% of our company.
Both: And we're your
"Shark Tank" weather girls!
‐[ Chuckles ]
‐Today in the Tank,
it's gonna
be 75 degrees and sunny
with a 20% chance
of rain.
Perfect day
for some shopping.
Come on! Hurry up!
Let's go!
♪♪
[ Thunder rumbles ]
Oh, no!
Emergency weather update!
It looks like
Hurricane Barbara's
about to hit
the Tank!
[ Rain pouring ]
Quick!
Everybody take out
your rain gear!
[ Chuckles ]
[ Thunder crashes ]
Both: Oh, no!
It's really starting
to come down!
Morgan, what about
our handbags?
They're gonna
get ruined!
If only there was a raincoat
for your handbag!
[ Laughs ]
There is, silly!
We invented it!
‐[ Laughs ]
‐We're the sisters
behind the Handbag Raincoat!
The Handbag Raincoat is
a chic and innovative way
to protect your handbag
from all of Mother Nature's
elements!
It comes in
three different sizes,
so we've got you covered
no matter how much
you like to tote around.
[ Laughter ]
With the
Handbag Raincoat,
you never have to worry about
getting stuck in the rain again.
‐[ Chuckles ]
‐So, Sharks...
Both: Who wants to join us
and own the rain
with the Handbag Raincoat?
And now
we have some samples.
And we're gonna pass out
some samples.
‐[ Laughs ]
‐Are you okay?
‐Yes.
‐A little wet, but we're okay.
‐Just a little wet.
So, Barbara,
we have one for you.
Yellow ‐‐ my favorite color.
Thank you.
‐Lori.
‐Pink.
‐Mr. Wonderful, for your wife.
‐Thank you so much.
How do you know I don't have
a bag I want to cover?
[ Both laugh ]
Thank you.
‐Sara.
‐Thank you.
Mark, this is
for your wife, also.
Mark, this is for your wife.
Thank you. Thank you.
♪♪
What do you sell them for,
and what does it cost to make?
[ Velcro scratches ]
It costs us
$1.79 landed.
They hold ‐‐
‐All sizes are the same price?
‐All sizes.
‐All sizes are the same.
They wholesale
for $5, $7, and $9,
and they retail
for $11, $15, and $20.
Can you tell us
your background?
So, first, Indiana.
Go, Hoosiers.
‐What? Go, Hoosiers.
‐[ Laughs]
‐Yes.
I graduated Indiana,
and I love fashion.
I majored in fashion,
and I worked for 6 1/2 years
as the director
of merchandising
for a large handbag company
with 80 girls.
And every day
it was raining at work,
all the girls would be like,
"I'm not using my handbag today"
or "I'm gonna use the worst
handbag in my closet."
I call Arley. I'm like, "We need
to figure out protection."
So, we bought
shower curtains,
we started cutting them on our
living‐room floor with scissors,
and we came up with
our patent ‐‐
utility patent pending
for the closure ‐‐
for the hook‐and‐loop
closure of the Velcro.
It lets you get
in your bag easily
and then seal it back up.
And this is a new category.
This never existed before.
What have you experienced
in just sales?
‐To date ‐‐
‐And in what period of time?
How long have you
been in business?
We've been in business
just about three years
right now.
Both: And to date, we've done
over $600,000 in sales.
Do you guys always talk
in stereo at home?
Do you guys talk in stereo?
‐Like, do you two actually ‐‐
‐We're only 22 months apart,
so it's kind of ‐‐
‐Is there a mind meld
where you actually
talk together?
Greiner:
And it's super cute.
You're almost
like twins. I‐I ‐‐
Everyone thinks we're twins.
What about this year?
That's just inception.
This year,
we've done, um, to date
$125,000 ‐‐
$125,000 in sales.
[ Laughter ]
Corcoran: Do you sell
entirely online,
or you're also
selling retail?
Both: No.
First, we did the, um,
test market online
at Bed Bath & Beyond.
We passed that.
Then they put us in
20 doors, then 100 doors.
O'Leary: And they reordered?
‐Yeah.
‐And they kept reordering.
What ‐‐ What other
big‐box stores are you in?
We're ‐‐ We just
got into Nordstrom,
Bed Bath,
Container Store.
Why have your sales
not blown up?
$125,000 for a great idea
like this
should be in the millions.
I mean, I don't understand.
So ‐‐ So, we have not done
marketing or advertising yet.
We feel that we've done
these sales organically.
We were actually
in Oprah's magazine.
From there,
we were put on...
Both: "The View."
We sold 10,000 units.
So, right now,
we're at a break‐even.
We ‐‐
How much money
have you put in?
We raised
$360,000...
‐Ooh.
‐Whoa.
‐Wow!
‐...through friends and family.
‐From friends and family.
And it was basically to help us
get off the ground
to buy our first
few rounds of inventory.
Did you sell them any
of the company for that?
So, we own around 84%
of the company.
Don't you think people are gonna
knock this off pretty fast?
So, we do have
two design patents.
We've already shut down
two copycats.
Cuban: Good for you.
You have? What did it
cost you to do that?
Both: Yes.
‐It cost us about $10,000.
‐I'm just curious.
They ‐‐ It was
a smaller company ‐‐
That's not bad, actually.
‐To us, that's ‐‐ that's bad.
‐To us, it's bad.
Yeah, but it could
have been a lot worse.
O'Leary: How many more
have come back up?
So, right now, a very, very,
very large handbag company
came out with
a Handbag Raincoat,
and on their website,
they are calling it
the Handbag Raincoat.
‐What?!
‐No.
And it costs $650.
...$50.
Greiner: Whoa!
Cuban: Okay, so, guys,
what do you need
a Shark for?
We're really looking
for strategic partners
and growth capital.
We have
other ideas that ‐‐
We have backpack raincoats
for backpacks...
Shoe covers.
...shoe covers.
We can expand on the brand
to fully own the rain.
This product is our blood,
sweat, and tears.
Our parents have really
supported us.
We're willing to do
whatever it takes
to make it work...
Cuban: No, you're not.
...'cause we know
it's gonna work.
I don't see that, guys.
I'm sorry. I'll ‐‐ I'll be
brutally honest.
I don't see that you're willing
to do everything it takes.
I get the vision
and I get the goal,
but in the interim,
y‐you've had all these ‐‐
these peaks where
you've had opportunity,
and it hasn't
really translated.
You're hoping
something triggers
so that the pull‐through
is there.
And when you're hoping
for that
as opposed to controlling
your own destiny,
that's why it's been
challenging.
And for those reasons,
I'm out,
but I wish you guys the best.
‐Thank you.
Cuban: I want to tell you
the way I'm seeing it.
You said you had no marketing
or advertising,
which was a plus.
‐Correct.
I see that as a negative
because marketing
and advertising is gonna be
one of your most major expenses
you're gonna have to encounter
if you're gonna grow
this business.
You said that you had
a potential lawsuit.
You've spent $10,000 so far.
That's nothing
compared to what you're gonna
have to do to stop a giant.
I'm out.
Listen, I see
so many similarities
from my journey
with you guys.
I was knocked off
by a lot of big guys
right when I came out.
I had a patent on my product.
I chose to keep inventing
and coming out with
the next best product,
but it's
a personal decision.
I chose not to sue and
not to go after everybody.
Based on how much I would use
the product myself,
which is part of what
I like to invest in,
I'm out,
but I wish you guys
great success.
Thank you.
Okay, let me give it
to you by the numbers.
Love numbers.
This business is not worth
$1.2 million.
You overvalued yourself
by a factor of 10 times.
I was intrigued by the fact that
a behemoth knocked you off
because I know how to fix those
problems very quickly, but ‐‐
‐Help us solve that.
‐No, but ‐‐
I love to pour money
on the gasoline of sales,
not litigation.
I know how to fix it,
but that's not a great place
to build value.
You're not gonna stay
on the shelves of retail
with $125,000 in sales.
Sorry to have to give you
the bad news.
The stereo stuff, all that,
I love it,
but the numbers ‐‐
‐So, help us out.
The numbers tell the truth,
and, honestly, I can't ‐‐
We'll make you proud.
We will.
There's just no way
to make money with you.
I'm out.
So, I think the umbrella
is why you haven't sold more.
If you have an umbrella,
it's protecting everything,
including the purse.
It's cute, it's kitschy.
‐Lori, offer us a deal.
‐I‐I don't ‐‐
I feel so bad 'cause
I adore both of you.
I'd hire both of you.
‐[ Laughs ]
But on this product,
I'm out.
‐Thank you.
‐Sorry, guys.
Blakely: Thank you, guys.
Congratulations on
what you've accomplished.
Thank you.
‐Can we just say to them
"good luck"
in unison?
One, two,
three.
All: Good luck.
‐[ Laughing ] Thank you.
‐Thank you.
‐See you, guys.
‐Bye.
♪♪
Sarner: I think they focused
too much on the numbers.
I know that they're
looking to make money,
but it's scary to open
a new category,
and we're
gonna do that.
Sara, what do you think about
litigating a behemoth?
Blakely:
I would not do it.
At this stage
in their business,
in relation
to their sales,
they have spent
way too much money.
Listen, when ‐‐ when ‐‐
when Spanx first started,
it was within a year,
I got a call
from a big,
big competitor ‐‐ like,
the behemoth,
and they said,
"Sara, we're interested
in learning more about you."
They flew to Atlanta.
Three months later,
they launched
an $8 million ad campaign
with a girl who looked
exactly like me
on billboards and buses
across the country.
‐Oh, my God.
‐Really?
And I did not go after them.
I did not go after them.
I mean, I had ‐‐
I started it with 5 grand.
Greiner: You couldn't, right?
I was like, "Where do I
want my focus?"
Like, I need to be inventing,
marketing, selling...
Yes.
Right.
...not ‐‐ You know, I just ‐‐
I had to make that decision.
Not to do a lawsuit.
And you know what?
That's a major point.
If you're always defensive
and working on that,
you're not wanting
your business.
Right.
♪♪
Narrator: Next up
is a way to get the most
out of travel rewards programs.
♪♪
Hi, Sharks.
My name is Jon Hayes,
I'm from
Raleigh, North Carolina,
and I'm seeking $200,000
in exchange for 5%
of my company, RewardStock.
Sharks, frequent‐flier miles
and other travel reward points
are so hard to use.
Most of us get frustrated trying
to find a good deal
or, worse yet,
ignore points altogether
because it's just
too much work.
At least it used to be
until now.
When my wife and I got married,
we took an amazing honeymoon.
We flew first class
to the Maldives
and stayed for eight nights
in a $1,000‐a‐night
over‐the‐water villa.
We got over $40,000
worth of travel
for just 200 bucks in cash.
‐Wow.
‐That's right. How, you ask?
By strategically using
our frequent‐flier miles
to pay for almost
the entire trip.
And that's when RewardStock
was born.
RewardStock is your automated
reward travel advisor
and booking service,
and it's really easy to use.
Simply create a profile with
any points you already have,
and search
where you want to go.
RewardStock figures out
the best way
to use your points to get there.
Your next adventure could
start before you know it.
And just like that
[Snaps fingers]
you're in paradise.
[ Gasps ]
[ Drum rattles ]
[ Hula dancers shout ]
[ Laughs ]
♪♪
Get up and dance with them,
Kevin. [ Laughs ]
Thank you.
Thank you, dearest.
Thank you so much.
Aloha.
Oh, my goodness.
Now we're cooking.
Ooh.
Oh, my God!
[ Shouts ]
♪♪
‐Whoa!
‐Whoo!
Bravo.
♪♪
Oh, gosh.
Ah!
[ Cheers and applause ]
‐Yes! Absolutely.
‐Someone get that man a drink.
[ Laughs ]
‐Fabulous.
Whoo!
Dancers: Aloha.
‐Aloha.
‐Bye! Aloha!
‐[ Chuckles ]
‐Don't try that at home, kids.
Right?
Sharks, what you've just seen
is a small slice
of an awesome
experience I had
on my most recent trip
to Hawaii
that cost me just 16 bucks
for round‐trip flights.
So, who wants to help me
bring experiences like this
to travelers everywhere?
‐Wow.
‐How do you make your money
on this kind of a deal?
‐Using my ‐‐ my honeymoon
that I mentioned
as an example, right ‐‐
this trip to the Maldives ‐‐
the way that I got this deal
is that I earned miles
with one airline
and traded them at
a 1 1/2 times exchange ratio
into hotel points.
‐Mm.
‐I then used those hotel points
to book this awesome room.
Nice.
At the same time, I earned
points with a second hotel,
traded them
with a bonus multiplier
into a second airline program.
I then used
those airline miles
on a third
airline travel partner
to book my first‐class flights.
‐Wow.
‐The average person ‐‐
‐That sounds so complicated.
‐It is.
The average person
will never figure out
how to do something like that.
‐Yeah.
But now they don't have to.
The way you would book that same
trip and get that same deal
at RewardStock is simply search
"the Maldives."
Our system will analyze
your profile,
figure out all of
the strategic elements to it,
and simply show you
the best option for you
based on the criteria
that you've set.
‐All you have to do ‐‐
‐So, wait, does it curate,
like, all the miles
that you have
from credit card,
from airline...
Yes.
...and all of that?
That's exactly right.
You put that
into RewardStock...
That's your profile.
‐You create ‐‐
‐...and that's your profile.
And then you just figure out how
to make the most out of that?
We execute all those complicated
transactions for you.
So you don't even have
to know how it's happening.
You just know you're getting
the best deal.
Are you familiar
with a platform
called Honeyfund?
‐I am.
‐That's my "Shark Tank" deal.
Yeah, absolutely, Kevin,
and that's actually why
I see a lot of synergy here
because ‐‐
‐Yes, I see it, too.
‐[ Chuckles ]
Well, it's good when we see
the same thing.
O'Leary: Yeah.
What is RewardStock making
on the transaction?
Okay, there's a few
different ways.
We charge a $29‐a‐year
membership fee.
On top of that,
we earn referral revenue
when we connect
our users to products
that will help them
earn more points quickly.
Oh, so, if someone
signs up for a new car,
you're getting paid
a referral fee.
‐That's exactly right.
‐Jon, what's your gross revenue?
Did you mention that?
‐We launched our beta site,
uh, two years ago,
and in that time,
we've done
$50,000 in sales...
‐Wow.
‐That's it?
...on 10,000 users.
And in that testing period,
we've been a free platform.
We've just been gathering
feedback from users.
So, that is basically $5 a user
of pure referral revenue,
and we've actually
even considered
being a free platform
altogether
and focusing purely
on the referral revenue,
and ‐‐ and that ‐‐
that's exactly where ‐‐
Jon, tell us about
your background, et cetera.
So, I mentioned
I'm from Raleigh.
I went
to Princeton University.
When I graduated,
I moved to Manhattan.
I did mergers and acquisitions
advisory for seven years.
O'Leary:
Now you're talking.
I was a top‐ranked investment
banker the entire time.
Um...
Greiner: Good for you.
After this
amazing honeymoon...
[ Laughs ]
...I realized that there
was big opportunity here,
so I quit my job
on Wall Street.
I spent the next year
teaching myself
how to write code and building
the prototype for the site.
Jon, what are your biggest
business challenges
that you would see?
We're a four‐person team
currently,
and we only have one
full‐time programmer
in addition to myself.
That's our biggest bottleneck.
How much money have you spent
so far on your business,
and can you shed
some light
on how you get
to $4 million valuation?
I have personally invested
$20,000 of my own cash,
and we've raised $700,000
of additional capital.
‐Wow.
‐At what valuation on the 700K?
$3 1/2 million valuation cap
on a convertible note.
That was $400,000
in that note,
and that's how we get
to the $4 million valuation.
Jon, I have
to be passionate
about everything
that I invest in,
and this is
not my wheelhouse.
I'm gonna wish you
all the best,
but I'm out.
‐Well, thank you.
Okay, I think ‐‐ super smart,
what you're doing,
but I think it's just
too early
for me to feel comfortable
with my investment.
So, for that reason,
I'm out.
You're still in search
of the perfect model...
Hmm.
...and that's gonna take
a lot of money,
and I think it's gonna take you
a while to get there.
$50,000 is not a lot of revenue,
so for that reason, I'm out.
Okay.
Uh, well, I appreciate
your time, Barbara.
Pleasure.
I'm interested 'cause it fits
right into some of my platform,
and, uh, we could add a
tremendous amount of value in ‐‐
in kind of kicking this off,
but I'm not doing it for 5%.
No way. I just ‐‐ I just
add too much value.
Hmm.
You got to get me to 10%
and I'll do it for 200K,
but I'm not
doing it for 5%.
You're not worth
4 million bucks right now.
Well, what I would say is ‐‐
and I ‐‐ and I described
how we got to our valuation
to begin with, right?
‐I understand.
‐Mm‐hmm.
But none of your investors
have my platform.
Kevin, um...
I appreciate that offer.
Uh, let me
ask you, Mark,
what are you
thinking about this?
I‐I'm gonna need
to get to 10%, as well.
Because at 5%, you're gonna need
me a lot more than I need you.
Um, part
of my concern on ‐‐
on ‐‐ in sensitivity
on valuation
is that I've got these
convertible notes that
are gonna convert
when I ‐‐ when I do
this deal, right? So ‐‐
I'm guessing
they have a discount.
Uh, 8%, yeah.
Okay, so, if I gave you
320K, 10%,
then ‐‐ and you gave me
1% advisory share
just so I didn't give you
more money for nothing,
then you will overcome
your hurdle, right?
So, 320K, 10%,
1% advisory share.
We'll formulate it
so that it works within,
um, your note
when it converts.
♪♪
Mark,
you got a deal.
‐Done.
‐Yay.
‐Done. I had no doubt.
[ Laughs ]
‐Good deal.
Appreciate it.
Congratulations.
Thanks, man.
‐Congrats.
Thank you all so much.
Got a deal with Mark Cuban.
He's gonna help us put some
additional capital in.
We'll increase our technical
resources, and we'll be able
to deliver this solution
to people all over the country.
‐Here's to RewardStock.
‐Hey, hey.
‐To RewardStock.
‐And me making lots of money
and having Kevin call me
all the time.
It won't
be happening.
[ Laughter ]
Crying
'cause he wants in.
♪♪
After appearing
on "Shark Tank,"
we've expanded cricket chips
to over 1,200 stores.
And we're getting millions
of people eating bugs.
So, here's
to "Shark Tank"
and another 10 years
of changing lives.
And making dreams
come true!
‐Whoo!
♪♪
Narrator: Next into the Tank
is an innovation
for a common household tool.
♪♪
Hello, Sharks.
My name is Eben Dobson,
founder of WISP Industries.
And I want to introduce you
to the WISP,
a revolutionary
floor‐cleaning system
that's in the process of
disrupting a category
that hasn't changed
in centuries ‐‐ sweeping.
We have literally
re‐engineered the broom
and the dustpan
from the bristles up,
making for a more efficient
and unique action
we call WISPing.
We all know what it's like to
use an old broom and a dustpan.
It requires two hands
and a side‐by‐side motion.
To use the pan,
you got to bend down...
It's true.
It's a pain.
...putting strain on your back
and your knees,
and we all know
what it takes
to get that
last pesky line of debris.
Well, no more.
[ Broom and dustpan clatter ]
[ Laughter ]
The WISP is intentionally
lightweight,
to be used with one hand
in a pulling motion.
The bristles are short, dense,
and 90 degrees to the floor
to create a perfect seal
to that surface.
The patented WISP pan
is amazing.
It literally allows you to apply
pressure with your foot.
Simply step
on the back, here,
and see how that creates
that perfect seal...
‐Ah.
‐...allowing you to easily
bring in that debris
effortlessly.
‐That's smart.
‐On the side of the pan
are combs that allow you
to clean that bristle.
‐Wow.
‐The evolution of sweeping
is WISPing.
That's why we're seeking
$500,000 for 10% of the company.
So, come on, Sharks.
‐That's a lot of WISPing.
Who wants to join
Team WISP right now
and make sweeping changes
all across the world?
Have you sold
any of these things?
Yes, we've sold over
100,000 units to date.
‐At how much apiece?
‐We've done over $3.3 million
in sales, lifetime.
‐Wow.
Is any of this
protected, or...?
‐All of it.
Everything you look at
has a design patent
and utility patent,
as well.
So, what was
your profit last year?
Did not have
a profit last year.
Why not?
We had a loss due to two
very significant events
where it ate into our margin.
We were on a couple shows where
we had to do revenue share.
There was an inherent
marketing cost
to reach that many eyeballs.
So, you offer
your product at half price.
It's 50% off to the customer...
‐Right.
...so, basically, if you have
a 50% markup on your product,
you make no money,
but you get
a lot of eyes
on your product.
We sold 20,000 units
in four hours.
‐But at no profit.
‐Very little.
O'Leary: But what about
the rest of the year?
What was your sales
last year?
‐$1.43 million.
‐You made no money on that?
We lost $600,000.
‐Oh!
‐Lost?!
‐Wow.
‐How'd you do that?
H‐‐ That's hard to do.
That's not easy to do.
There was a lot of decisions
that I made,
and I take full responsibility
for it.
I had many people
that were on, um,
a consistent kind of
compensation schedules,
and I learned that
that was ‐‐
when times were lean,
that that was a bad decision
on my half...
Employees?
‐...and I've made those changes.
Well, if ‐‐
Like sales reps and
distributor type things?
Yeah, and people that "market."
Eben, how much
have you invested,
and how much have you raised?
I've raised, uh,
close to $2 1/2 million
over six years.
They cut ‐‐ Golf company ‐‐
You've been doing this
six years? Wow.
So, we don't
even know ‐‐
what does one cost,
and what does it cost to make?
The configuration
you're looking at right here
costs $29.95.
And our cost of goods
in '17, were $8.50.
O'Leary: So, the problem
is you're competing
with an $8.99 broom.
‐Yes.
And how much do you have
in inventory there?
We have about $300,000.
Why did you buy
so much inventory?
In 2016, we went viral
to over 110 million views,
and we sold out like that.
[ Snaps fingers ]
So, instantaneously, I went,
"We need more inventory."
We brought it in.
‐You got caught up.
Because it took time,
all of our search and exposure
started dissipating,
and we had to start that
back up again.
So we did another event,
and we keep doing
this roller coaster.
What we're looking at,
with your help,
would be to bring in a more
consistent, economical way
to create a supply chain,
and then really go after
what we believe
is our online edge.
Okay, so what are
your cumulative losses
since the beginning
of inception?
Like, what ‐‐ How much have you
lost in these years total?
He's raised
$2.5 million.
Does that mean
you've lost $2.5 million?
Do you have any money left?
We have about $50,000.
♪♪
Okay, so, you have
$50,000 in the bank,
$300,000 in inventory,
some IP,
but, effectively,
you're down $2 million.
More.
$2.1 million in the hole.
♪♪
Narrator:
All Sharks are still in,
but they've discovered that Eben
is over $2 million in debt
for his broom business, WISP.
Effectively, you're down
$2 million.
More. $2.1 million
in the hole.
Well, I don't believe
I'm doing a really good job
of painting
the exact picture because...
[ Chuckles ]
You think?
‐Well, but ‐‐
‐...um...we ‐‐ we know
that the products will sell,
and what I'm here for
is to ‐‐ is to, uh ‐‐
I've made mistakes,
and I've ‐‐
I think you get
an "A" for effort
and an "F"
for execution.
And I think
you know that.
And so, for those reasons,
I'm out.
Look, the product
clearly works.
I mean, that's
the intriguing part.
But in year after
year after year,
you've made no money.
That's very depressing.
And so, the question is,
do you need
adult supervision
so that you get focused
on one thing?
'Cause there must be somebody
that wants a broom that works.
It's just,
how do you find them?
It's why I'm here.
Because I've been punched
for three‐plus years,
and ‐‐ and, um, I've been
working off instinct to go,
uh, and optimize,
uh, cost of goods ‐‐
But where did you raise
the $2.5 million from?
Well, from, um,
my network. Uh...
And nobody has come in
since then saying,
"What the hell
is going on?"
Well, um...
"Let me take over.
Let me give you some help."
‐...I never raised enough money
to really
drive the business.
I always did it
project‐based,
and it's been
a long time coming.
We did a ‐‐
‐It's $2.5 million.
Each one of us started
$100 million‐plus businesses
with thousands
of dollars.
Look, we all make mistakes
as entrepreneurs,
but I just
really don't think
you have your act
together on this.
For those reasons,
I'm out.
Okay.
Sorry about that.
Eben, I have
this theory.
When you're first starting
a business, make it, sell it.
Make it, sell it.
I feel like you've spent
a lot more money
maybe than you
needed to.
And I would take
a hard look at that.
One of the things that
I say to people is,
"As soon as you can afford to,
hire your weaknesses."
Your contribution
to this
feels like it should be
more in the product side...
‐Mm‐hmm.
‐...and I would encourage you
to get support on
the marketing/sales side
so that you can really focus
on the part of the business
that I can feel
is your strength.
‐Okay.
‐And I like your product.
I'm gonna buy
your product, actually,
but I'm not gonna invest
in your company today.
So, I'm out.
Thank you.
Innovation
requires education.
Eben,
it's a great product.
It needs
to be demonstrated.
It's been
a very rocky road.
You certainly need a partner
to be your mirror image
and do all the things
you don't do well.
You have some weaknesses
in executional skills
when it comes to business.
Not everybody does it well.
‐I admit it.
‐That's why they partner.
Mm‐hmm.
‐You desperately need a partner.
‐Yes.
Someone with executional skills
and certain disciplines
about how money is spent.
That person's
Mr. Wonderful.
So, if you
want $500,000,
I'll do it, but I want 50% ‐‐
not 51%, 50%
'cause that's
a lot of money.
I don't like
losing $500,000.
I don't do that ever.
‐Right.
But do you have debt
on the company, too?
Very little,
comparatively.
‐How much?
‐$250,000.
Oh.
[ Laughing ] I knew
where that was going.
‐This story...
‐Gets longer.
Well, I don't ‐‐
I don't know
if you can sell me
50% of the company.
Who owns it?
Well, I have, uh ‐‐
I have, uh...
22 investors...
‐Wow.
‐...that have been through ‐‐
‐22?
Yeah, it's been
a long road of ‐‐
‐Oh...
‐I feel like I'm at a wake.
Honestly, I don't think
I've ever sat here
where I felt like something
really took my breath away.
Oh, my goodness.
I mean, I just
was like, "Whoa."
It's like
a punch to the gut.
You have so much debt,
and you've lost so much money.
‐What are you gonna do?
‐How do you recommend
I get out of this and ‐‐
and fight for it?
More things as the onion
keeps unpeeling.
I mean, there's got
to be a chance ‐‐
Cuban: You need
somebody who ‐‐
who's just
a killer salesperson.
♪♪
You know, I've ‐‐ I've had
every opportunity to quit
from all of the things
that we're talking about,
but I believe in it so
strongly, and I'm so passionate.
I own a basketball team,
and I'm smart enough
not to put myself
on the court.
I can't wrap my arms around
so much debt.
It's so bad.
If you can get Kevin
to invest all the money,
I will help him and you
to sell it.
‐You ‐‐ Do you w‐‐
‐You put up the money,
I'll do the sales.
Do you ‐‐ Do you want
to put up $250,000?
I ‐‐ no.
You put up the money...
Okay, well, then, I can
call you later
after I restructure it.
...and I'll roll up my sleeves,
and I'll do the sales.
Okay, that's something
we can deal with later.
Look, Eben, I'll put up
the $500,000,
but one way or another, I'm
ending up as a 50/50 partner.
Now, if your 22 investors
don't like that outcome,
they don't like it
because they're not here,
but you are.
Right.
So I'm gonna make you
that offer.
If you're willing to accept it,
let's go to work.
There's a lot of work ‐‐
And he's not interested
in doing anything
to bring me in
to help you sell it,
so I'm out.
Well, Lori, I can
discuss that later.
She's out. Okay. Look, maybe
we'll work with Lori later,
but right now,
you need $500,000.
She's not willing
to put up a cent.
I am. I'll put up
the $500,000,
but I got to end up with 50%.
Yes or no, Eben?
What do you
want to do?
But why wouldn't you
not want to include Lori?
I might, but she's not putting
up any money right now,
so I'm not
worried about it.
I think you need me.
Eben, if you want to do
a deal with Lori,
do a deal with Lori.
She has no money for this deal.
What do you want to do?
This is your moment.
Yes or no?
♪♪
‐He wants ‐‐
‐Okay, we'll do it.
‐Wow.
‐There you go.
‐But...
‐But!
‐But? Wait.
‐Come on in.
‐What? Did I hear a "but"?
‐But wait, there's more.
‐Yeah, he didn't include me.
Don't lose her number.
Remember, he did not
include me...
She has no money.
...so now you gave 50%
of your company to him.
I know her number.
I can call her any time
I want or if I need her,
and she'll come running.
Maybe. Maybe not.
Well, do you have anything that
we could ‐‐ you could add?
I really think that ‐‐
‐That's it, Eben. I'm out.
‐Oh!
‐Get out of there.
I'm gone.
I'm an investor.
Okay.
I had the $500,000.
It was in your hand,
and you're talking to her?
You're out of here.
See ya, buddy.
‐Goodbye. Take your broom.
‐Good luck, Eben.
‐Bye, Eben.
‐Oh.
Kevin's offer was amazing,
but I don't believe
that I have the ability
to make that decision
that quickly.
That could have gone better.
But the truth of the matter is,
is that I'm not
going anywhere.
The WISP is still
gonna be available.
Now he's made three mistakes
to the next potential investor.
That was too tough.
I'm sorry.
That was so painful.
Honestly, I should have
never had anything ‐‐
I'm s‐‐ Are you
out of your mind?!
That was too tough
for that man.
I'm going up there
to shake his hand,
and he's still
talking to ‐‐
Too mean.
You know why?
Oh, I'm "too mean"?
Oh, God, I feel terrible.
No, no. No, you know why?
Because ‐‐ No.
He's not a businessman.
‐Wait, wait, let me cry.
♪♪
Narrator:
In season 9, Liz Martin
made a deal with Lori Greiner
for her kid‐friendly
hairbrushes,
Tangle Pets.
I know that you're
the perfect partner.
I know ‐‐ I knew that
walking in here.
Narrator: Let's see what
they're up to now.
♪♪
Martin: I've been a big fan
of "Shark Tank" since it began,
and so I knew that Lori
was the key.
We're launching these
on QVC, as well.
[ Squeals ]
My Tangle Pets were cute.
With Lori's help,
they've become epic.
Super‐functional brush,
super‐adorable characters,
and high quality.
Before "Shark Tank,"
I was selling Tangle Pets
at school fundraising sales.
Tangle Pets is now launching
nationwide in 50,000 locations,
and we have done $12 million
in retail sales.
♪ Tangle Pets ♪
♪ The brush in a plush ♪
An infomercial can be amazing
for a product like this.
People see it, we make it
catchy and memorable,
and then the retailers are
more apt to bring them in.
‐Now, look here.
‐Oh, my gosh!
‐It's beautiful!
‐Aah!
Bed Bath & Beyond!
Everyone wants to be
in Bed Bath & Beyond.
I use their coupon.
[ Chuckling ] Sorry.
I will now
have to go there even more.
Isn't it amazing?
[ Sniffles ]
You okay?
Seeing the product on such a big
scale at such a big retailer
confirmed in me
what I believed in myself
and I wanted others
to believe in.
[ Shouting and laughter ]
Greiner:
Liz was just an ordinary mom,
but she had
an extraordinary idea ‐‐
all it takes
to change your life.
What do you
think?
Martin:
Being a part of "Shark Tank"
is my happily ever after.
I hope that it gives inspiration
to other moms
when they know that
they have a good idea,
to go for it.
♪♪
Narrator: Next into the Tank
is an affordable way
to make a trendy beverage
at home.
♪♪
Hello, Sharks.
My name is Kate Field,
and I'm from
Madison, Wisconsin.
Today, I'm seeking $350,000
in exchange for 10% equity
in my company.
Now, Sharks, I'd like
to introduce to you
your new best friend.
The SCOBY!
‐What?
‐What?!
Blakely:
[ Laughs ] Oh, my gosh.
Okay.
I know it looks
a little gross...
‐It does.
‐[ Laughs ]
...but what if I told you
that this right here
is the key ingredient
to the fastest‐growing
beverage in the country?
‐It looks like a kidney.
‐Ew.
‐[ Laughs ]
‐Yep.
If you haven't guessed it
already,
I'm talking about
the wildly popular drink,
kombucha.
Filled with
healthy probiotics,
kombucha is a fizzy,
low‐sugar, fermented tea
with an addictingly
delicious taste
that consumers just
can't get enough of.
The problem is,
most kombucha in stores
costs a whopping
$3 to $5 per bottle.
And with ingredients like this,
brewing kombucha at home can
seem like an intimidating task.
So, that's why I started
The Kombucha Shop.
♪♪
We've taken what was once seen
as a slimy and scary process
and created a fun
and easy‐to‐use kit
that guarantees anyone
can brew kombucha at home
and for a fraction of the cost
of store‐bought 'buch.
[ Chuckles ] 'Buch.
With our brewing kit,
you can even learn
to make your own
custom flavors
all for as little
as 25 cents a bottle.
I've built a profitable
and growing company.
Now I need
your help to scale
and bring affordable kombucha
into homes everywhere.
‐Do we have samples?
‐You're not gonna make us
drink it, are you?
‐Yep. Oh, yeah!
I brought along some samples
to share today.
Okay.
Uh, let everybody else
have them first.
[ Greiner laughs ]
I think you guys
are gonna be surprised.
Really?
Lori, you have a sip.
‐Thank you.
‐Lori.
‐Let me see if you live.
‐[ Laughs ]
♪♪
Blakely:
Thank you.
♪♪
‐Okay.
‐Aah!
[ Laughs ]
Okay, so, before you
start drinking...
I can't see!
[ Laughter ]
...I want to tell you that ‐‐
‐It tastes like medicine.
‐Ohh.
Oh!
I actually think I'm growing
hair on my chest.
Oh, I should have never
let you guys taste it!
[ Laughter ]
But I'm just gonna say, millions
of Americans can't be wrong.
I think you're right.
My wife ‐‐ My wife
loves this stuff.
It's true. It's all over
the health‐food stores.
‐Wow.
‐I mean ‐‐
Yeah.
Sell us on the benefits.
Tell us why you would
go through this abuse.
Because once you start drinking
it, you actually acquire
a very serious taste for it
and love it.
In The Kombucha Shop, I don't
speak to the health benefits.
We don't make any claims
or anything like that.
Good for you.
‐No, it's ‐‐
‐Why not?
Because
the fermentation process,
there are probiotics.
It is healthy, right?
Exactly. It is.
But that's not my job to do.
So, people who come to us,
they love kombucha,
and they already know
the health benefits.
So, would you ‐‐
It feels good in the stomach,
though, I must say.
It does right away.
It does! And that's what
a lot of people say,
is it helps them
digest food better.
I drank some, and I'm a ‐‐
I'm a little, you know ‐‐
I'm ‐‐ I'm feeling
it burning,
but that's not what ‐‐
‐You're growing hair!
It ‐‐ It's not what's
burning my stomach.
What's burning my stomach...
‐On your back.
[ Laughter ]
...is $350,000 for 10%
imputes a $3.5 million
valuation.
Yes.
I have an unsettled stomach
until I hear revenue.
So, lifetime sales to date
are $3.2 million.
‐Wow!
‐Unbelievable.
‐Good for you.
‐Wow. Wow.
‐What about this year?
This year, we're on track to do
between $1.6 and $1.7 million.
Where are you
selling?
So, we're a predominantly online
direct‐to‐consumer brand.
We sell on Amazon,
on my website,
handful of
brick‐and‐mortar stores.
How much have you done
in Kickstarter or Indiegogo?
‐None.
‐None?
No, I started this company
with $800.
‐Good for you.
Greiner: Wow.
So, Kate, I'd love
to see how it works.
Basically, what you do is
you're gonna make sweet tea,
then you're gonna open up
that SCOBY pouch,
and you're gonna
pour it in.
So, you can see that little
SCOBY's down in the bottom.
You're gonna put
the cotton cover on top of it.
You'll follow
the instructions.
There's pH strips.
You'll do a little test,
you'll put a temperature gauge
on the side,
and then it's gonna just
sit on your kitchen counter
for approximately
10 days,
and the fermentation
is complete.
So, you're obviously
selling a lot...
Yes.
...and doing great.
What do you need
the money for?
So, I'm here for a strategic
partner to scale.
I've brought this company
as far as I can on my own.
I've been a one‐woman show
this whole time.
What I've learned is that
I don't know what I don't know.
I crush it online, and I've
learned everything that I can,
but I don't know retail.
It's a market that I don't
have access to right now,
and I know where my customers ‐‐
‐Well, what ‐‐ what ‐‐
what's your dream retailer?
Where would you
want to sell this?
Whole Foods.
Those boxes take up a tremendous
amount of shelf space.
That's why I stacked
these here 'cause this
is how I pictured this.
You go into
Whole Foods, right?
They do tons
of these little products
that are sitting in
the middle of the aisle.
Kate, have you tried to ‐‐
You didn't give us
some numbers on your cost
and what you sell it
for, did you?
So, this kit right here
is $11 to make.
We sell it retail
for $45.
The deluxe kit is $23.
We sell that for $75.
Kate, I got bad news.
These are barely enough margins
to play
in the retail space,
considering they won't
pay you for 60 days.
I mean, you've got such
an amazing business.
Let's go back to
the business you have.
$1.7 million this year.
What are you gonna make
after you pay yourself?
Just over $500,000.
‐Wow!
After you ‐‐
After you pay yourself?
Wow.
Why screw that up?
Greiner: Amazing.
That's after
I pay myself.
What does it cost you to acquire
a customer ‐‐ a new customer?
Currently zero. I've never
put any money into advertising.
Yay!
[ Laughter ]
Okay, so, you're
gonna make $500,000
after you've paid all
your staff and yourself.
Yes.
So, we're gonna pay some tax
on that this year.
So, you're gonna have
$300,000 left
when that's all done,
which is great.
Yeah.
But because it's not
proprietary or protectable
and all that stuff, you have
to start thinking
about what multiple
as an investor
would I pay on $300,000?
‐Oh, Kevin.
Just ignore everything coming
from his mouth going forward.
But wait ‐‐ But I want to give
it to you anyways.
Well, it's a good point.
It's not ‐‐
Obviously,
I can't make a kit.
It's not proprietary, but ‐‐
‐No, I get it. I get it.
But I'm just saying ‐‐ $300,000
this year after taxes.
That's great.
‐Yeah.
I'm not gonna offer you
12 multiple on that.
I'm gonna offer you
half of that.
I'll give you
$350,000 for 20%.
Let the bidding begin.
Okay, so,
I like to be
really into, like, the products
that I invest in...
‐I know.
‐...because it makes me excited.
I'm just not
a kombucha fan myself.
For those reasons,
I'm out.
Kate, when I invest
in someone,
I like to really understand
what value I am adding,
and I'm still
unclear on that.
When we asked you why you need
the support and the money,
you said,
"To go to retail."
Your margins right now
don't really support retail,
and you're doing so great
in direct marketing.
So, I'm struggling with
why you wouldn't
just continue to do this
by yourself.
So, I don't see retail
as being a huge distraction.
It see it as an additional,
helpful piece,
and I really see it ‐‐
I mean, have you called
Whole ‐‐ Whole Foods?
I've talked ‐‐ I've ‐‐
I've talked with a few buyers,
and they've ‐‐ It ends up
being the runaround of,
you know, "Oh, yeah,
we got your product,"
and six months later ‐‐
‐So, Kate,
giving up a lot of equity for us
to call Whole Foods for you ‐‐
So, I'm here because
I want to blitz.
Competitors are coming.
There's new ones on Amazon...
‐Yeah.
‐...every month.
And so, yes...
Feel ‐‐ Yeah, you feel
threatened.
...I can keep waiting
for them to call me back,
but they don't, and it could be
18 months, 24 more months
before I'm in six or seven
regions of Whole Foods,
and I want to go like fast.
‐Hey, I'm not gonna ‐‐
I'm not gonna buy 10%
of your company
so I can make a phone call
for you to Whole Foods.
I want you to stay the course,
keep doing what you're doing.
Sara ‐‐
Okay, so...
♪♪
And?
Wait, wait,
Sara.
♪♪
Narrator: One Shark is out.
Kate has one offer
on the table from Kevin
for her kombucha‐making‐kit
business,
The Kombucha Shop.
I'm not gonna buy 10%
of your company
so I can make a phone call
for you to Whole Foods.
I want you to stay the course,
keep doing what you're doing.
Sara ‐‐ Okay, so...
And?
Corcoran:
Wait, wait, Sara.
Why don't I
just make a deal
and if you'd like to join me,
you're more than welcome.
Okay.
But not Mr. Wonderful, of
course, 'cause he's obnoxious.
[ Laughs ]
You're gonna overpay.
I'm not gonna join you.
I'm not
gonna overpay.
Sure you are.
Watch ‐‐ Watch this.
All right, well, what are you
thinking, Barbara?
What are you thinking?
‐Watch this.
A couple of things.
First of all,
there's a lot of things that
you're not even mentioning
that I'm noticing that makes you
a dream entrepreneur.
You're a great designer.
‐Thank you.
That is so adorable,
every little piece.
You're so specific...
Yes. Very true.
[ Laughs ]
...on detail,
but yet, you're phenomenal
at the big picture.
Thank you.
The thing
you're not utilizing
is that gorgeous face
of yours.
Oh, God!
Are you aware
that you're probably
the healthiest‐looking person
I've ever seen
in my entire life?
Yeah, I was gonna say
the same thing.
[ Laughs ]
You're a poster child
for this.
[ Laughs ]
If I could be as
healthy‐looking as you,
I would swallow this horrible
stuff every day of my life.
‐[ Laughs ]
‐I was thinking the same thing.
Barbara, start drinking
kombucha.
‐Your skin, your hair.
‐I'm telling you! It ‐‐ It's ‐‐
So, Barbara, how much
are you gonna overpay?
I'm gonna give you
$200,000 in cash,
$150,000
in a credit line,
if you need more than
that in a credit line,
no issue,
based on orders ‐‐
for the 10%,
what you're asking.
So, if you'd
entertain that offer,
I would love
to be your partner.
Hold on, hold on.
Barbara, I will split
the deal with you.
‐Okay.
‐And you'll get both of us
for what
you're asking for.
‐Wait, so, wait, wait, wait.
‐I'm gonna take that deal.
Yay!
‐Aww.
‐Oh, my God!
‐Congratulations!
‐Thank you.
‐Yes. This is great.
‐Congrats.
I'm gonna make this
at home tonight.
I can't believe it.
[ Laughs ]
♪♪
Oh, I'm ugly crying
on TV right now.
I have admired Sara and Barbara
for so long.
But, honestly, I would have done
a deal with Mark.
I admire him so much, and...
I'm a little sad he didn't
even get to get an offer in.
Mark, I had a feeling you
were gonna overbid us.
Am I right?
‐Yeah, in a heartbeat.
It would have taken me
one phone call
to get them
into Whole Foods.
Why were you so quiet?
Normally, people at least
give me a shot.
And if she didn't want
to, maybe she just didn't
want a deal with me, so...
No, not at all.
Not at all.
She probably just...
Ah, don't take it
personal.
...didn't realize it.
She probably just
liked the deal.
♪♪